in an earlier video I've written down a
form for the cost function for logistic
regression in this optional video I want
to give you a quick justification for
why we'd like to use that cost function
for logistic regression so quickly recap
in logistic regression we have that the
prediction y hat is sigmoid of W
transpose X plus B where a sigmoid is
this familiar function and we expect
that we want to interpret Y hat as the
probability that y is equal to 1 given X
so we want their algorithms output Y hat
as the chance that Y is equal to 1 for a
given set of input features X so another
way to say this is that if Y is equal to
1 then the chance of Y given X is equal
to Y hat and conversely if Y is equal to
0 then the chance that Y was 0 was 1
minus y hat right so Y high was the
chance that Y is equal to 1 then 1 minus
y hat is the chance then Y is equal to 0
so let me take these last two equations
and just copy them to the next slide so
what I'm going to do is take these two
equations which basically define P of Y
given X you know for the two faces of y
equals 0 or y equals 1 now let's take
these two equations and summarize them
into a single equation when just a point
out Y has to be either 0 or 1 because
we're in binary classification so y
equals 0 1 are the only two possible
cases right but someone think these
equations and summarize them as follows
let me just write out what it looks like
then we'll explain why it looks like
that 1 minus y hat to the power of 1
minus y so it turns out this one line
summarizes the two equations on top let
me explain why so in the first case
suppose Y is equal to 1 all right so Y
is equal to 1 then this term ends up
being Y hat
because that's why I had to the power of
one this term ends up being one minus y
hat to power of one minus one so that's
the power of zero but anything depart
zero as you go to one so that goes away
and so this equation just says P of Y
given X equals y hat when when y is
equal to one so you know that's exactly
what we wanted now how about the second
case what if y equals zero if Y is equal
to zero then this equation above this P
of Y given x equals y hat to the zero
but anything to the power zero is equal
to one so you know that's just equal to
one times one minus y hat to the power
of one minus y so one minus y is one
minus zero so this is just 1 and so this
is equal to one times 1 minus y hat is
just equal to one minus y hat and so
here we have to the y equals zero P of Y
given X is 0 1 minus y hat which is
exactly what we wanted above so what
we've just shown is that this equation
is a you know correct definition for P
of Y given X now finally um because the
log function is a circular monotonically
increasing function you're maximizing
log of P of Y given X should give you a
similar result as optimizing P of Y
given X and if you compute log of P of Y
given X that's equal to log of Y hat so
power of Y 1 minus y hat is a part of 1
minus y and so that simplifies to Y log
Y hat plus 1 minus y times 1 1 minus y
hat right and so there's actually
negative of the loss function that we
had to find previously and there's a
negative sign there because usually if
you're training learning algorithms you
want to make probabilities large whereas
in such as regression we're expressing
the
if we want to minimize the loss function
so minimizing the loss corresponds to
maximizing the mark of the probability
so this is what the last function on a
single example looks like how about the
cost function the overall cost function
on the entire training set on M examples
let's figure that out so the probability
of all the labels in the training set
and writing there's our local informal
views if you assume that the training
examples I've drawn independently or
drawn iid an identical independent
distributed then the probability of the
examples is the product of probabilities
or thousand from I equals 1 through m of
P of Y given X I and so on if you want
to carry out maximum likelihood
estimation right then you want to
maximize the find the parameters it
maximizes the chance of your
observations in training set but
maximizing this is the same as
maximizing the log so I'm super long
from both sides so log of the
probability of you know the labels in
the training set is equal to log of a
product is the sum of the log so that
sum from I equals 1 through m of log p
of y i given X I and we had previously
figured out on the previous slide that
this is negative L of y hat I Y I and so
in statistics as a principle called the
principle of maximum likelihood
estimation which just means to choose
the parameters that maximizes this thing
or in other words then maximizes you
know this thing right negative sum from
I equals 1 through m L of y hat I Y I
and I just move the negative sign
outside the summation so this justifies
the cost we had for logistic regression
which is J of W P of M this and because
we now want to minimize the cost instead
of maximize our likelihood we've gotten
rid of the minus sign and then finally
for convenience or the initial that our
quantities are better scale we just add
a one of em extra scaling factor there
but so to summarize by minimizing this
cost function J of W B we're really
carrying out maximum likelihood
estimation with the logistic regression
model under the assumption that our
training examples were on my ID or
identically independently distributed so
thank you for watching this video even
though this is optional I hope this
gives you a sense of why we use the cost
function we do for which is Russian and
with that I hope you go on to the
exercises that prone exercising the quiz
questions for this week are best of luck
with both the quizzes and for an
exercise